[Music]
all right thank you everybody for
attending this session this is the best
venue I've ever had an opportunity to
present anything in so I'm gonna enjoy
that and for the folks who may be
looking at it on the stream afterwards
we're in an IMAX theater so if I try to
make a few movie jokes that's why so
this session again thank you very much
for joining us that the conversation for
today is around Internet of Things and
how to find ROI return on investment
hopefully the folks in this room have
experienced some of I uh but it's around
the Internet of Things connecting things
to the Internet and within IOT there is
a couple of different angles one is
technical right we hear a lot about IOT
technologies MQTT and TLS and lots of
three-letter acronyms and that is
important but there's a whole other side
of it which is IOT is not just a
technology but it's a whole new business
venture I don't know about the folks in
the room but like I haven't met my first
you know chief IOT officer so IOT is
still very new and many enterprises are
trying to figure out how it fits into
their organization as part of that one
key aspect of it is ROI like how where
is the money in this stuff and a lot of
the companies that we work with and that
we see are trying to figure that out so
quick introductions and we'll dive right
in so I'm Adam Michaelson and I'm a
product manager inside of Google IOT
core which is Google's IOT offering so
my job is to build some of that tech to
make sure IOT products are safe and
secure reliable low latency but also
hopefully build a product that folks in
the enterprise can drive real value from
and frankly that's as much if not more
challenging than building a technical
product with low latency and high
security so before we dive right in I
want to do the other introductions of
the guests who are joining us which I'm
super excited about so when I learned
about this session and feel and Doug
would be joining joining us it was kind
of an honor because it's so exciting to
see when IOT is being used in the field
and have customers and actual users come
forward and offer us their advice around
what's working with IOT from a money
perspective and what's not and that's
what that's what the feeling Doug you're
here to talk about I'll give it the mic
over to them for in a second to
introduce but as a quick introduction so
Doug Stanley he's a partner of Google
and he has a company called neo labs
that specializes building in building
IOT solutions and has an IOT product to
help customers and then fill ads Mundson
he he owns a winery very cool and he's
an agriculture business so it's Phil's
job to figure out is ara is is IOT worth
it it is there are ROI in it so to have
these folks here today to share their
experience it is is an honor for myself
to present with so Doug Phil can you
introduce yourselves I am Jack Stanley
hi I'm Doug Stanley I'm the CEO and
co-founder of neo labs it's a really a
pleasure to be here on behalf of our
team we're very very excited to actually
share with you a real IOT implementation
that is getting real results we were
recently with Google at i/o tea world in
their booth and the overwhelming
reaction we got was is this really real
and so I think that was a my take away
around the state of the market and so
we're excited today to not only share
the tech but the results of something
very real built and along with my wife
Kim were the owners of deep-sky vineyard
and adam said you wanted to tell you a
little about bit about how IOT and ROI
might come from that in the field in
this case it literally is in a field I
am NOT a longtime wine guy except for
enjoying it but for until four years ago
I was a vice chairman and let our
technology media and telecom practice at
Deloitte so I come from a tech
background
very easy for me to get into this and
I'm excited to share what we've learned
that deep sky vineyard as we dive in so
a quick survey so when it comes to IOT
and in the audience here just a quick
raise of hands in terms of how many
folks are experimenting with IOT
in their organization which is like
somebody somewhere has a Raspberry Pi
doing something or an Arduino or an
Android things connecting great it looks
like the vast majority we see that as
well and there's sort of ages of IOT
we're still much very much at the dawn
of IOT so I think we're all together in
this journey to figure out how IOT
functions but we do see a lot of folks
who want to experience with IOT have
connected something so sort of like the
connectivity age where maybe we're in
the middle of or maybe at the end of in
terms of can I guess get a device
connected so the next question and is
around how many folks in the audience
have full-blown IOT products supported
in the field with customers using it
your call center can answer questions
your your documentation warranty is out
there how many of the folks have that
less which is what we expect so that's a
lot of the the things that we want to
talk about today is sort of that gap IOT
is new right so we don't expect a lot of
IOT products that are fully fully out
there in the field but there is a pretty
dramatic gap that's sitting in between
the amount of projects being piloted in
the amount of projects in the field so
there's a term that's being thrown about
I look at it sort of whims with whimsy
which is pilot purgatory if you google
it it's a generic term but it's very
much being associated with IOT and what
it means is we started a project we
haven't finished it we're trying to
figure out you know how does the
connectivity work how do all these
components come together and how it is
exactly provide business value
for for my boss my shareholders my
university whatever it may be
so this cons of the pilot purgatory I
think is very relevant when it comes to
ROI one thing that we're seeing is what
is the one of the major challenges
around why products in projects get
stuck in pilot purgatory so this is just
a study by McKenzie there's many such
studies there that are similar but this
is a good one to take it as an example
which is around 84 percent of the
companies that's the start of the pilot
are still in it a year later that's a
lot right in IOT is new and the promise
of IOT is great
so our bosses allow us some flexibility
to run pilots but a year's a long time
30% are still in a pilot two years in in
around 30% of projects I haven't even
have gone to production so 70% of the
projects haven't even exited pilot so
there's something here holding projects
back according to this study the top
three factors are executive support so
does the seat whatever keeps the CEO up
at night is IOT solving it maybe not a
strong business case and also strong
internal organization alignment so I
think what's interesting here is these
are not technical challenges these are
business challenges so the thesis is
that many of the reasons we're stuck in
pilot purgatory isn't just all the
technology is getting woven together
it's how do we establish ROI in what's a
methodology to find the revenue inside
of IOT so why and how certainly the how
of IOT is super interesting certainly
for geeks like me like connecting all
this stuff here's an example of
underwater some underwater technology
underwater cameras that Google has that
we part up with Caitlin and that's
what's powering underwater Street View
so if you google underwater Street View
you can like explore the Great Barrier
Reef very cool if you're building a
device like this then I'd recommend we
spend a lot of time
technically proving this like how does
how does the device work underwater how
does why
if I work underwater I've known it
sounds like a good little interview
question now that I think of it I I
actually have no idea so if this is what
you're dealing with then spend a lot of
time with technology entire inside of
your pilot's if it's not then the
suggestion is that you should we should
trust our devices we will get them
connected very rarely do we see a device
that can't be the challenges is a lot of
IOT technology out there so how do I get
the right security protocols the right
connectivity protocols keep it secure
have a create a device registry
basically it's an assembly challenge of
getting the right components assembled
to create an IOT solution but we should
all have faith for the most part that
the device will be connected but the
challenge is really is really the why if
we spend a lot of our time 80% of our
effort on the on the how and that's what
our labs look like and maybe 20% on the
why we're stuck in pilot purgatory we
need to balance that out a bit so we've
done is worked with a number of
customers to come up with a framework
that is pretty simple where we can
discover the the why where is the ROI
and that's what I want to present right
now so this is one of the key slides
around that we show some customers and
prospects and walk them through so
there's direct ROI it's the best type so
I did this IOT project and because of it
I derived actual value so when it comes
to direct ROI there's a couple of sides
in the balance sheet simple right I can
sell more I can save one way to sell
more is feature enablement it's a cooler
product so if you think of like b2c or
even b2b if if I have a product that has
iot capability it has more features
because of that people may buy it it's
also a great reason to refresh so you
know upgrade to the IOT product versus
the one that wasn't which is great all
revenue is good revenue the problem here
is it's a one-time purchase right and
every time we IOT enable the device we
the cost of that device goes up because
we have to pay to get that keep that
device connected what we've seen is that
device can cost anywhere from
like 25 cents a year to a dollar or more
year to get connected that increases
your bill of materials right and if your
margins are high on your products and
your lifespan is relatively low on your
products maybe five to ten years you may
be able to absorb the bill of materials
difference but very few companies that
we deal with can write it's competitive
market so what other techniques do we
have to generate revenue beyond just the
individual sales some of these out of
categories so sales enablement what
we're talking about here is
replenishable it's kind of the razor and
blade story so I'll give you the razor
for free if you'll buy my blades so from
a replenishable perspective if we can
create a product or we can identify that
something has been consumed create a
subscription automatically send it to
you we can create a subscription model
and that's the Nirvana of ROI the next
one down is service enablement here you
think of sort of like anything as a
service like if you want to be cool at
an IOT cocktail party say um something
as a service so the idea is like I am an
HVAC provider but since I know the air
quality of the indoor building I can say
I'll sell you air quality as a service
and the higher the better air quality
you want the more you'll pay me in and
I'll figure out when to switch out all
the various filters so that's service
enablement and then the Nexus scale in
pricing which is that if you become
operationally efficient enough then
sometimes your product you can actually
produce more product than you used to be
able to and maybe even charge a premium
so it's just another avenue to achieve
money on the right-hand side are around
efficiencies right think of a warehouse
so increased uptime I added one more
nine to my number of nines on my on my
manufacturing floor we lowered risk for
your employees by IOT enabling equipment
and make sure nothing hits somebody
resource efficiency certainly to make
sure that you're consuming your
resources effectively and then a higher
quality product so you may think of more
based on your your vertical but these
ones we've seen work again and again for
80% of the businesses we work with so
direct revenue now we see all this
indirect revenue
okay so this is a blessing and a curse
this indirect revenue is the promise of
IOT
it's where phrases like data is the new
oil comes from or big data and data
science and the idea is you collect you
sensor all your data put sensors on it
collect lots of data and then money
comes out the other side except very
rarely does that happen these indirect
revenue impacts are meaningful but if
all of our business cases are based on
them then we can definitely get stuck in
pilot purgatory because we're looking
for long-term money that is a little
hard to connect so to go around the
wheel really quickly in the upper-right
targeted marketing its the idea is that
manufacturer who makes whatever a
dishwasher now that I get to know my
customer better through IOT and because
of that because I know my customer my
customer segment I can market to them
more effectively building better
products I see how customers are using
my products therefore my next Rev is
going to be of a higher quality and
enhanced brand
I guess the marketers could debate this
but in like b2c anyway when I put IOT
enabled the brain becomes a little
cooler like a little blue light shows up
and it's just an you're a you're a
cooler brand new business services so
we've seen customers who are like in the
electrical business they'll make a surge
suppressor and now what they can see is
there's been a surge maybe some of the
equipment is out so what they can do is
create join the gig the gig economy and
have electricians who are roaming around
give the deal deal to them to go and fix
the job so I used to be a manufacturer
and now I'm participating in the gig
economy brand-new business opportunity
and then customer engagement this is
where like a customer calls into your
call center now you can see their device
most manufacturers are participating in
IOT know the customer basically through
a warranty card but now through IOT in
an app I can know the customer directly
that's a responsibility but it's also an
opportunity to increase my NPS my Net
Promoter scores because I can service
the customer I can get a first-time fix
so all these are great what we see is we
go around the
born here work with customers and say
check off as many of these as you can to
say how you're going to generate ROI and
what we'd love to see is an early pilots
right so many of us are in pilots we
just saw like a raise of hands try to
get as much a direct revenue as possible
because you could prove to your business
in a short term that this is valuable
and then around the outside the indirect
revenue may be even larger opportunities
but those will become second once you
have more time rolled out a larger pilot
collected more data and had the
opportunity to mine that data the more
check marks the better it's just a
little bit of a warning sign if they're
all on the outside ok so what I want to
do now is it's pulling dug and pull and
fill and have them walk you through the
specific agriculture example what did
they find on this what were the bet so
they were placing at the beginning of
their project what was the reality of
what they found and how can we also
learn from from their mistakes that's
what we want to do as well as as well as
what they accomplished for for and apply
that obviously to the to the folks in
the room so done thank thank you gotta
and so just to keep his frame of her in
mind we were able to look back at the
deep sky project over in our third year
actually we're in our fourth year and
third year sorry
how are you thinking about next year and
have a really accurate view of did we
achieve our goals you know make no
mistake Phil as Phillip mentioned that
he was a former Deloitte partner I too
am a former Deloitte partner we knew how
to do business case and we know
certainly know how to do ROI we think
these frameworks are very solid tools
and frankly we followed the methodology
we didn't make decision to move forward
deep sky until we had collective
alignment between our customer the
Asthma sons and each given ear and our
team so and fortunately which was sherry
to do we're going to granular level and
on the results a little bit later but as
you look at the the wheel of fortune
here of ROI benefits we really hit the
ball out of the park and again I'm
excited to share it with direct as well
as the intangible items and you'll hear
about Phil talking about some of the
strategic they're making
that's their making now because of these
frankly longer-term benefits but first
you view indulge me a little bit Neil
Labs is not an Ag tech company that's
the first thing I think that surprises
people truth be told we decided to
connect this vineyard because of a
screaming phone call I received from a
former partner at Deloitte the outrage
of him watching his wife get up and
drive two hours to their been here just
to see if the water was turned on and so
that started the conversation we had a
big pain point from the customer you
know to our surprise the it was an
amazing qualifying application for us
for our platform we still operate in a
horizontal business model and we have
lots of demand for AG our preference is
to be that horizontal platform and
partner with others so let me take you
through a little bit of the experience
that deep sky vineyard this is about two
minutes long
pharming it's the oldest industry on
earth and arguably the most important it
feeds the world employs millions
sustains life and it's under siege
agriculture consumes 70% of the world's
water its most precious resource a
single almond the size of a thumbprint
requires just over a gallon to reach
maturity put another way that water that
California uses in a single year just to
grow almonds is enough to serve all the
homes and businesses in the Greater Los
Angeles area for nearly three years
farmers rely on diverse data and
generations of accumulated experience to
do what they do but farming is still
farming and operating margins are slim
the oldest industry on earth also has
the oldest challenge consume less
produce more the data that empowers 21st
century farming pours in from sensors in
the ground that measure moisture content
from water volume monitors deep in the
aquifer from weather stations and from
generations of experience and knowledge
but here's the challenge how can all
that data become a single meaningful
real-time indicator of how the crop is
doing well there is a solution
imagine that you're a vineyard operator
with the ability to log into a mobile
app to see contextualized data from
thousands of sensors telling you
everything that's happening in your
in real time from anywhere in the world
that same app helps you anticipate and
respond to equipment failures before
they occur through rich predictive
insight and provides detailed
information about the vineyards
microclimate imagine receiving requests
for water directly from the plants and
having a system that can automatically
respond or being able to focus
specifically on one row of lines or on
the data for the senior plant imagine
being able to view and analyze the color
of the grapes on that plant or the ratio
of the Sun above the canopy to the shade
below it this is precision agriculture
this is neo we combined millions of
unrelated complex data points and
convert them into a simple visual richly
insightful experience and the result
lower cost and resource consumption
higher crop yields and better product
quality precision agriculture is a
game-changer for farming when experience
combines with real-time data collected
at the plants themselves we redefine the
world's oldest and most revered industry
and that is only the beginning
we are outrageously proud of the work
we've done a deep sky vineyard but we're
also pragmatist about this and the
partnership that we formed with the
Google now has us frankly we're reciting
the Google terms we think about
precision agriculture is it is it
scalable for the planet let me take you
through as you're developing a use case
for for ROI for a for IOT one thing that
people tend to forget is number one as
Adam mentioned they focus really too
much on the how I'm a big lesson we
learned man we really overwork this we
did everything in this vineyard as Phil
could attest we built the boxes we built
the specs we dug the trenches we augered
the holes we did every single aspect of
it
initially we wanted to know the
challenges that our platform users would
face when they took our product into the
market but frankly we really overdid it
right so I would tell you focusing on
the why we did a great job of that but
think about the macro economic
opportunities that IOT can unlock you
know the reality today is our farmable
land has decreased by 40% by 2050 we
have to increase our food production by
70% today you know nobody's pining to go
into farming where there's a massive
labor shortage I won't get political I
promise and then lastly farming consumes
70% of the freshwater on our planet and
it's trending towards 80 or 90 percent
now the big bomb that we all need to
consider is it's a known fact that 60%
of the water used in farming is wasted
now later we're gonna get into a
granular experience and deep-sky
vineyard and frankly the stats add up so
now we're gonna actually take you into
the vineyard you know in our limited
time here one one morning I have you you
can go in and it's a real time
experience from the needle out website
or you can go to our booth and I want to
get pitchy but you can look at deep sky
vineyard in real time any time you want
Philips not gonna let you control his
vineyard and he's not going to disclose
his private reporting tap that I'm that
I'm not going to expose to you here but
let me
I do that okay there we go oh that's it
we're done Jack Jack Jack Jack bear with
me one second technical problem up here
comes the man okay if it works so great
in our warm-up the demo gods you know
while we're waiting to do that let me
just give you a little bit more history
on deep sky itself and how a guy with 34
years at Deloitte senior partner there
vice-chairman ended up you know
scratching dirt for my 50th birthday my
wife decided to take me down to
Argentina we had a hell of a lot of fun
in fact so much fun that instead of
buying a shirt we bought a vineyard and
came home 27 page document in Spanish
sure enough how to translate it we had
bought a vineyard it's kind of a
condominium vineyard but a vineyard just
the same around the same time we were
moving out to Arizona from Connecticut
and while we were out there driving
around I happened a comment to or how
much it reminded me of Mendoza Argentina
so she decided to go out and check
around if there was a wine industry
there sure enough there was and about
six months later I got a text that said
hey about 20 acres of land down in
Wilcox Arizona and we're gonna plant a
vineyard that's literally how we got
here today at that point in time to put
certainly my wife he's done a fabulous
job with this in a perspective we have
no live plants in her house at all
they're all dead so we had to replace
them all with silk plants and so I had
to ask her said what in God's name makes
you think you can grow vines suffice it
to say that was kind of the battlecry to
challenge to her and she has done a
magnificent job and it is really done
wonders over planted it in 2011 so -
through today it has made tremendous
strides and this is kind of a
culmination of what we wanted to do to
really make sure we were growing the
best grapes possible because in Arizona
nobody knows the answer to that yet it's
very much like our name deep sky it's
exploration there is no right or wrong
nobody has the magic formula neo is
helping us find those form
so what I'll do is I'm gonna just drop
you through a little bit of the user
experience and how Phil and then frankly
turn it over to Phil and he'll tell me
where to navigate he'll take you through
how he uses the platform on it on a
daily basis so we start obviously with
the proverbial dashboard view which he
takes a glance at he peeks at his
irrigation we have multiple ways of
capturing the weather macro and all the
way down to micro even down to leaf
moisture now the interesting thing about
farming your macro forecast your
weathermen can tell you it's raining
like hell and you don't get an iota of
water in a farm or it can rain in one
block of a vineyard and not in another
but more importantly if it's windy you
won't absorb any of that wine so we have
multiple sensory capability down to even
a weather station on site as well as
within the rows and just to re-emphasize
this is live so it is a hundred and one
degrees down there right right now he
takes a look at the equipment diagnostic
some pumps neo is fully instrumented
throughout that factory so well all the
way through pressure and flow throughout
various sensors he has the ability to
add observations from the vineyard this
is something I'll expand on a little bit
later he looks at the events of the
vineyard and lasting all spent a little
bit of time on this it's it's certainly
squint print you can see it for yourself
but SystemVue this is these are
streaming perspective of what's
happening in vineyard alt all time by
block it's a really a powerful
diagnostic you know one thing that I
learned many years ago you know fakery
we don't only get you so far in
innovation so everything you're looking
at here is real and fortunately for us
that the as mice's allows to expose it
to to the world frankly real-time deal
so let's walk us through walk us through
a day okay for me you know the dashboard
go go down to weather real quickly now
there's a couple other things here daily
et that that kind of down here and the
up up there on the right side know the
two inches you'll see daily et that's
really a measure of how much water the
plants are basically expiring to cool
themselves down that's what they use
water for it brings nutrients up but
they're also using it to cool it down so
you know looking at this for
you know GDD is-is-is degree days and
that's an indication you need a certain
number of growing degree days in order
to get your fruit ripe and so we
actually track that so that we know
about how far we might be from harvest
because we have that history from year
to year so there's more there than just
might meet the eye that UV index is very
important that UV index is an indicator
how much warmer that fruit will be if
it's in the Sun if it's in the direct
rays of the Sun you don't want that
fruit dorm up so too much fortunately
have a good canopy to shield that but
let's go onto the irrigation this is
where the real stuff starts and and and
kind of you know to set this up you know
Doug mentioned the the 100 mile drive to
our trip to get down there and have
having the ability to see remotely into
this vineyard was very much a driver and
that was kind of the start of it but it
really got its start when I watched my
wife and her vineyard consultant sit
there and auger hole after hole know
this is a big hand auger it drills down
about three feet she pulls it up and
there's a big clump of dirt in the
little cylinder there and they drop it
into their hands and they start
squeezing it and they yell out 55% 60%
and I just looked at my said what the
hell are you doing and they told me
they're checking for soil moisture and I
just decided there had to be a better
way and in my vision as I thought about
this I could see what was happening up
above the ground of the plant
I wanted to see into the ground what was
happening to the water when it went in
and what was happening to the water when
it went out and that's really what this
section is all about okay so why don't
you click on just just as a general
orientation the top is what we're all
irrigating this little map right there
the brown part over here is really a map
of the vineyard those are all the zones
well what did you do Doug we just
disintegrated the vineyard just
accenting it to read it again what
helped tempo help but you know seeing in
the ground is important because nobody
really knows what to do you don't know
what happens when it's a hundred one
degrees out and there were if you ask
ten vineyard operators down there you
know ten totally different answers
- what the right way to treat your vines
are and for the most part people just
said put 20 gallons of water on per vine
every 5 days and just do that but the
fact of the matter is soil is all
different and you're gonna see that here
so there's our map we've got another
little chart ok so you've gone into five
that's fine let's just go there for a
minute so this is where it kind of all
comes together let's go back to five
Doug that's five you'll see at the top
that 100.8 degrees that's at 101 you saw
before you'll see a recommended gallons
of 11 that's actually what we're putting
on if we went back up at the irrigation
screen you'll see that five is scheduled
to be water today for 11 gallons you'll
see something called available water
54.6% in field capacity 84 points then
I'll go a little into Field capacity
I'll try to stay away from available
water content except to just give you an
idea of what it is
why don't you scroll down Doug and we'll
get into this zone five sensor 5 area
the numbers on the left-hand side of
that chart over here then the numbers of
the left are actually the current soil
moisture percentages at each of those
depths those depths are 4 8 16 24 32 and
40 inches the number next to that is the
degree of the soil so as you would
expect it gets cooler as it goes down
it's gonna be warmest up at the top and
get cooler going down those are more
important to us when we're approaching
bud break when the plant actually comes
back up and you start to see green
because there's there certain
temperatures for different varietals
that will indicate when that's about to
happen so not quite as important because
remember this is now this is during
variation if nobody knows what version
is it means when these hard green
berries start to soften and in the case
of red grapes they turn red in the case
of white wine grapes they turn kind of
golden in color so this is the start
kind of the the prequel to the actual
ripening process during during harvest
those buttons in the middle the two that
are green are green because right now
those are our zones of interest we want
to try to make sure water gets to those
zones because those numbers over there
on the right hand side is the percent of
water that is being taken up at each of
those depths so let's just think about
that for a moment so what I know I said
I want to be able
look into the ground I not only watch
the water as it goes down into the
ground but I watch it as it comes out
and if you could just click on why don't
you click on the eleven gallon per vine
irrigation up there on this left side
Doug seven twelve oh that's the ten go
down to eleven if you could he was
always a great partner but he did not
well the eleven gallon one go down seven
twelve there you go there we go so um
you gotta look up a little bit on this
one but what you see is this tells me
what the starting and soil moisture
percentages were what the ending ones
were and then what this plus 24 is this
is important the way water dynamics work
and believe it or not it's incredibly
consistent from irrigation dhira Gatien
if you look all the way over to the left
you'll see something called observed FC
or Field capacity think of that as the
glass is full the soil that's the point
at which the soil can hold the water
against the force of gravity and you
really find that out not when the
irrigation is done because you'll see
those numbers are higher than the
twenty-four ones and what they're doing
is they're coming back down to field
capacity in about twenty four hours
later it's at that point that I start
capturing how much why how much water
the vines are pulling from each depth
and if you have follow across I think
it's sixty six point seven three and
sixty seven I'll see it better down here
and sixty six to sixty six point three
nine that'll almost be the exact same
thing all the time so that's why when
I'm looking at this and I'm trying to
figure out what I want to do I actually
went in and looked at that eleven gallon
per vine watering to see what happened
and that's the one I chose to do now
you'll see that if you went down to
fifteen go down to the fifteen one seven
seventeen for a moment just to show a
difference
seven seven sorry down there you go
right there you can see we practiced
this a lot which we did actually what
you'll notice on this one is the the
four and eight ended at sixty six point
seven and sixty five point five four and
they had a little bit of gain in the 16
inches but we used four gallons more to
do
and the reality is as you looked at that
uptake it's really not taking water from
16 inches so this is what we also
consider we don't want to over water I
think of water as the new oil so we're
constantly trying to minimize the amount
of water but hit the zones that we want
to hit that's what's most important and
we use that by making sure we know what
FC is tracking each one of these
irrigations and that's what we're
building our algorithms around so that
neo will just do it for us it already is
if you'd gone back to one of those
earlier earlier I think it was actually
the dashboard it was recommending five
for eleven point seven gallons I I
wouldn't go there Doug but um if you can
now Doug click on the open what's it
called yeah that one there you go so
wait a second here and you'll see
something and this is where it really
came to life for us this is a chart for
the last about month that shows the red
is irrigations and the blue line is
showing where we went to and you'll
notice there's great symmetry amongst
all of these we're trying this is
exactly what we're trying to do when you
can start to manipulate the water in the
ground and know what the vines are
taking up you have suddenly an
opportunity in the early part of the
year all raise all those lines up I'll
give it as much water as at once why
because I'm trying to grow the canopy
I'll do that right into early May at the
end of May when the when the fruit is
about to set I'll actually bring those
lines down because I'm trying to set
very small berries for a very simple
reason the flavor is in the skins so if
the berries are smaller your your your
fruitful skin is a greater ratio to the
pulp of the berry of the juice and so
you're gonna you bite by by definition
or theory you're gonna have more
flavorful grapes now every one of you
are gonna go be able to go out and get
drunk and buy a vineyard after this with
a lot more confidence but Philip we
better reel this in a little bit and get
to the benefits okay I'll do that all
right so let me let me close out take me
on that anyway suffice it to say this is
a total game changer for us I mean we
have confidence when we go to bed that
we know we've watered what we need to
water I don't wake up the middle night
saying oh my god have we
this we know we have neo helps us do
that okay Phil listen let's get to the
meat of it show me the money
show you the money well it's pretty
straightforward 30% labor efficiency
because we have them doing the right
things at the right time we're not we're
not guessing we have so much better
information about our vines that we can
direct our workforce to do what we need
them to do when we need them to do that
it says 40% reduction of water that's my
guesstimate for over the year in in June
it was well over 50% in in terms of
gallons applied in 2018 versus 2017 and
up to about a million gallons will be
saved this year at deep-sky and remember
this is a small twenty acre vineyard now
Doug I think you have some pretty
interesting take this notion a 15 acre
vineyard in Willcox Arizona saved a
million gallons of water right there are
eighteen and a half billion acres under
plant worldwide of viticulture if we got
1/7 of those 1/7 of these results
worldwide 185 billion gallons of water
that could be saved now as I mentioned
earlier coincidentally farming was it
wastes about 60% of the water that
that's provided Phillip is running fifty
to sixty percent savings so the value of
instrumentation this is think of
agriculture's of metaphor to many many
other markets right and the value of
connectivity and frankly a proper
platform so yep sure and those last two
crop efficiency and price lift I mean I
kind of look at those together a little
bit and it's this is really all about
quality at the end of the day everyone
wants to know how much water we're
saving and we are saving a lot of water
but I always say it's not about saving
water as much it's about using the right
amount of water but if you use the right
amount you will definitely save but it's
also about quality of fruit quality of
fruit definitely yields higher quality
wine we like to say 80% of the wine is
grown in the field and we're actually
seeing that and you know quality is a
subjective thing I mean you know you can
guess at it you can look at it but you
can taste it you can you can get the
tannins you can get the ripeness of the
fruit the fruit flavors and all that but
I'd rather look at my customers because
we don't keep all of our fruit we sell
less than half of it and we have three
main buyers every one of those buyers
now puts on their label something called
vineyard designation and their bottles
even though it will say name a winery
it'll say deep-sky vineyard right there
on the label as well they're doing that
because we've become known for higher
quality fruit and just putting our name
on their bottles lifts their ability to
sell it for a great amount of money so
that's the real to me that's the real
kicker to me because it really is our
customers are telling us your quality's
better which has allowed us to lift lift
our price and none of them are here but
that's going up next year as well
because we're really excited about our
crop this year one last thing to look at
seventy-five percent lower cost of human
error that was real we had people not
showing up we live in Marana Arizona
this is in Wilcox Arizona we had one one
month where the guy told us oh yeah
water and water and water and we got our
electric bill it was about twenty
dollars you couldn't run that pump for
for three or four hours without it being
20 bucks and the guy just hadn't done it
and and you know we couldn't be there
all the time but we needed that
visibility we took a cruise in Alaska
last year we were we were monitoring
that vineyard doing the entire crew
putting on water looking at needs of
water all of that all from a ship
somewhere in a fjord in Alaska with that
Doug turn it over to you yeah so the
road map and our progress today it is
one tip is again if you avoid the
overthinking the how but look for a
really quick win now in this case the
quick win was having Phillips stop
calling me screaming about his wife Emma
got two hours of check and see for the
water on was on or not trusting the
people managing their vineyard so we got
them the the confidence in the quick
wind that they could remotely manage
this vineyard very very quickly the
other thing that we discovered is that
the entire thesis about water usage
frankly it was wrong they thought they
were distributing I forget how many
gallons it was now but it was Lily's one
fifth was the actual amount once we
instrumented the vineyard the water that
was getting to the plant was a small
percentage of what they thought it was
okay so that was a real quick win the
first year we connected to connected the
system God has stabilized really focused
on the user experience
made some adjustments to it last year we
made further modifications went in and
tuned some algorithms filled us a lot of
back work data crunching this year has
been extremely productive we're turning
the ROI up he's transforming his
business as he mentioned he's getting
things like vineyard designates we're
really achieving the goals frankly none
of this is a surprise
from the original vision we had
alignment that this could happen but
frankly there's a leap of faith right so
we focused hard in the quick win and now
we're really seeing no pun intended the
fruit of our effort now the super
exciting part particularly with the
partnership with Google is we're really
looking forward to next year refining
this instrumentation and computation
model starting to incorporate ml both
from a data standpoint as well as some
video analytics we can talk more about
that offline we're getting a little
short on time but you know frankly this
project is is now it's just too
compelling we as a company are thinking
about you know how do we scale this so
even though we're gonna stay horizontal
we're now very focused on this the
results are just undeniable lastly for
the for the tech audience I'll give you
a quick flyby I think now this is a
second day of next so you've seen slides
that looks something like this but this
is really an elegant marriage between
Google handling the cloud elements and
our neo platform handling everything
below we are a distributed edge
processing platform so you see the data
flow it starts with in my world it
starts in the far right we have tightly
wrapped IOT core into our deployment
model we use it it's functioning we use
it in everything we do now it's working
beautifully
Google is involving us and they're
forward-thinking about where the product
line goes and we're super excited about
that but we also remember now this is
this is Willcox Arizona Adam joked about
if you're not at the bottom of the ocean
well Willcox Arizona is is about like
being in a bot in the ocean it is a very
very remote place our gross networked
pipe is a 10-5 rural cell card that's it
that's all we've got now we're very very
efficient network management
numerous low-power networks operating
here but there's a lot going on so we
run a local network at the vineyard the
vineyards got a run it can't be
dependent on Internet connectivity and
that of course we we then filter and
share up to the cloud with pub/sub up
through into data flow bigquery and we
use think of it as our data warehouse
there and of course everything is
deployed with kubernetes so numerous
nodes ranging from quad core down to
single core nodes because neo is not
just a data capturing platform this is a
full control system this vineyard runs
on auto mode right it does not have to
literally Neil will run to make
recommendations and run to vineyards so
we've got mobile tools we have a lots
going on there we have recently
introduced a little bit of low raw as
well so it's a super exciting but for me
it's just it's a magnificent elegant
collaboration between Google and us and
a fantastic customer so it's just it's
just a win and on that I think I'll turn
it back over to Adam yes so yeah quick
closing thoughts so to kind of circle
back to the ROI hope that from the
context so agriculture is a major use
case for IOT manufacturing is a major
use case smart home medical we're seeing
a number of verticals begin to really
realize the the benefits and it often
starts in this sort of way it's like oh
I don't want to get up and drive two
hours
so in these boutique way our disruptors
right it's what the big folks are
worried about but for the folks in the
room who are already big folks it's good
not to start with these huge huge
aspirations with other data but start
with something small you know don't
drive two hours make the CEO happy and
then go from there
but when when looking for ROI the the
the good mindset is first think outside
your company
what's the macroeconomic trends in this
case its water it's labor shortage
what's happening in the world that's
gonna affect because we're kind of we're
skating to the puck with IOT
right it's gonna be a two to five year
journey so what's gonna happen
competitive disruption like we're saying
X as a service so are your competitors
shifting especially if you're
manufacture are they getting into the
are they becoming software vendors the
minute you launch an app you're a
software vendor in what what's happening
there in your industry and then
regulatory we didn't talk about here but
we see a lot of regulatory pressure and
where that comes in IOT is a great
release valve because IOT provides a lot
of transparency so rather than having
auditors having having expenses to deal
with regulation IOT can deal with it so
just some macroeconomic trends I'm sure
you can think of more after that you
think of your internals like the chart
we went through before internally
focused where can we find revenue get as
many tick marks as you can direct
revenue first indirect second and see if
that if your thesis is achieved it can
be achieved in a very small way at first
and lastly no ROI no pilot but basically
if you see 80% of your pilot effort in
our pilot effort is kind of precious
right you get you all an audience can be
doing lots of things with your time the
fact that so many hands got raised
around efforts around IOT we are all
responsible right for sort of exiting
pilot purgatory together in finding this
ROI it's not mission impossible huh
that's a movie reference well you know
and to that point Adam um we we talked
about this and and you know if a little
vineyard in Arizona of 20 acres can get
the kind of results we've achieved and
it wasn't easy I mean there were some
fits and starts but you know if we can
do it I can only imagine the impact you
guys can make on your companies which
are much larger and probably have a much
bigger you know Apple to take a bite out
of this stuff and so it's so quick
thoughts in terms of wrap-up obviously
we're in the middle of next here so
really appreciate your time
but given the number of hands that went
up around IOT we're really excited if
you haven't seen Google's IOT offering
yet please check us out so we're over in
the end
muskan self please come over to our our
booth and check it out and we'll show
you IOT core the neo labs folks are
there as well if you want to talk about
other IOT solutions or if you're into
agriculture or into one
become a sommelier so you could learn
more about the the industry and we have
a booth over there as well on and then
do please check us out at Google slash
Google Cloud IOT and learn more about
the solution and we'd obviously love to
hear your feedback as well within the
IOT group like I'm on the product team I
can tell you we're very interested I'm
and we are very interested to hear your
feedback so you can find me or anyone
else from the product team and just
would love to hear your use cases
because we're learning and growing
together and we'd like to thank you for
your time
[Music]